[Musique]
et Olivier fort je vous en prie
installez-vous merci beaucoup bonjour
Merci d'être notre invité politique ce
matin depu t premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste on va parler dans quelques
instants de la montée de l'antisémitisme
du projet de loi immigration qui arrive
au Sénat mais d'abord la situation en
Israël où les bombardements se sont
intensifiés sur la bande de Gaza qui est
désormais coupé en deux c'est ce qu'a
annoncé l'armée israélienne la France a
rappelé hier à une trêve humanitaire
c'est ce qu'a demandé Catherine Colona
est-ce qu'elle peut être entendue il
faut le souhaiter la situation est
extrêmement grave il faut rappeler que
tout ça provient d'abord d'un fait
générateur qui est en fait l'attentat
terroriste immonde qui a été conduit par
le Hamas mais on a aujourd'hui des
représilles qui sont totalement aveugle
et qui frappe indistinctement les
terroristes mais aussi la population
Gazaoui qui malheureusement n'a rien
demandé et qui elle-même prise en otage
par le Hamas et donc il y a une forme
d'absurdité
et de folie à continuer ce ce qui est un
massacre en réalité avec des potentiels
crimes de guerre c'est l'ONU qui le dit
et donc effectivement il faut arriver à
cesser le feu immédiat permettre cette
population qui est en fait dans cette
prison à ciel ouvert comme elle est
décrite maintenant de manière régulière
et bien comment voulez-vous que ces gens
puissent fuir toutes les frontières sont
fermés ils sont bombardés où qu'ils
aillent et donc ils sont dans une
situation qui est aujourd'hui intenable
impossible et toute humaniste doit
aujourd'hui s'inquiéter de cette
situation et réclamer in cesser le feu
immédiat Emmanuel Macron annonce la
tenue d'une conférence humanitaire à
Paris jeudi c'est une bonne initiative
bah c'est une initiative qui en tout cas
va dans le bon sens euh on ne peut pas
reprocher au président de faire tous ces
efforts pour
obtenir éventuellement une trêve
humanitaire ce que je regrette c'est
qu'en réalité dans cette conférence
Israël ne sera pas représenté et je
regrette que la parole de la France soit
pas un cran au-dessus parce qu'on voit
bien que en réalité c'est un cranudessus
ben c'est le C le feu immédiat permettre
de retrouver en fait un pe pas
simplement une trêve humanitaire qui
serait simplement une façon de souffler
et puis ensuite de repartir avec un
assaut qui a les défauts que je viens de
décrire mais c'est C feux que refuse
Benjamin netaniaou c'est ce que refuse
Benjamin netaniaou bien sûr mais c'est
pas parce qu'il le refuse que nous
n'avons pas nous la France à poser
d'autres principes il faut se battre à
la fois pour libérer les otages faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent rentrer chez eux
ensuite il faut demander à cesser le feu
immédiat et et il faut aussi rétablir la
possibilité d'un processus de paix qui
conduise à une solution à deux états
voilà ce que devrait être la parole de
la France elle ne peut pas être pas
selon vous fa elle a beaucoup bougé elle
a beaucoup évolué puisque on est passé
on est passé d'un soutien inconditionnel
un soutien que je crois aujourd'hui plus
mesuré parce que les faits sont sont là
et donc il y a une obligation de les
prendre en considération mais ça n'est
pas suffisant rappelons-nous de ce qu'a
été la position du général de de fr
mitteron de Jacques Chirac qui ont tous
tenu la même ligne et qui était une
ligne de fermeté y compris par rapport à
un allié historique qui est Israël mais
il faut savoir rappeler aussi de grands
principes parce qu'on est à un moment de
notre histoire où malheureusement le
risque d'embrasement dans les opinions
publiques il est là et il faut que on
puisse tenir cette parole qui est une
parole de raison et de paix vous
envisagez de vous rendre en Israël vous
mais je souhaite pouvoir y aller je mais
je n'aime pas beaucoup le tourisme de
guerre donc je ne souhaite pas y aller
dans un enfin pour l'instant en fait les
conditions sont pas forcément réunies et
je souhaite pouvoir me rendre non
seulement en Israël mais aussi auprès de
l'autorité palestinenne parce que ça n'a
aucun sens d'aller chez les uns sans
aller chez les autres il faut ouvrir ce
chemin pour la paix il est difficile il
est compliqué on sait bien on connaît
cette histoire depuis 75 ans qui est une
histoire d'une complexité qui n'est rare
j'allais dire peut-être pas tant que ça
en réalité mais enfin en tout cas qui
une histoire difficile douloureuse et
donc euh il faut prendre la tâche des
uns et des autres et et vous travaillez
là-dessus vous travaillez un déplacement
oui et à un moment où nous commémorons
il y a quelques jours la mort d'IT
saacraabine et ben bien il effectivement
il faut chercher à à reprendre à
remettre nos pas dans les siens et faire
en sorte d'apporter une solution qui
soit une solution durable et il n'y a
pas de solution durable sans respect et
sécurité pour à la fois les Israéliens
et les Palestiniens sur les conséquences
de ce conflit en France 1040 actes
antisémites ont été recensés dans le
pays depuis le 7 octobre c'est le
chiffre donné hier soir par
géraldarmmanin 257 à Paris et en petite
couronne c'est plus que sur l'ensemble
de l'année dernière comment on lutte
contre cette résurgence de
l'antisémitisme mais d'abord il faut
rappeler de manière récurrente
incessante que on ne peut pas tenir pour
responsable les Français juifs de ce que
fait le gouvernement israélien gouverné
par dirigé par par Benjamin netaniahou
et c'est absolument incroyable et tout
ça relève effectivement de ce qu'on de
l'antisémitisme comment rendre
responsable l'ensemble des Juifs de ce
que fait un gouvernement qui est un
gouvernement particulier et donc n
n'avons pas aujourd'hui malheureusement
en fait enin tout le monde n'a pas cette
présence d'esprit et donc il faut
rappeler sans cesse que l'antisémitisme
est un n'est pas une opinion c'est un
délit qui peut même conduire parfois au
crime et que malheureusement il y a des
résurgences à rythme régulier et ça
n'est pas assez multiséculaire
malheureusement l'antisémitisme est une
gangraine qui malheureusement a frappé
notre pays à de nombreuses reprises et
continue à le frapper et quand vous
rappelez le nombre d'actes antisémites
qui sont aujourd'hui constatés il y a de
quoi s'alarmer s'indigner et appel
est-ce sindigne suffisemment est-ce que
la classe politique est-ce que les
citoyens s'indignent
suffisamment je le fais devant vous et
j'espère être entendu euh il n'y a euh
enfin c'est c'est complètement enfin
c'est je récuse pour que tout le monde
me comprenne et y compris ceux qui
aujourd'hui en veulent au gouvernement
netaniaou c'est un c'est aussi imbécile
d'accuser les Français juifs des crimes
commis par benami netaniaahou que
d'accuser les Français musulmans des
crimes commis par le Hamas chacun doit
le comprendre personne ne peut
essentialiser cette crise cette guerre
et laisser penser que c'est un conflit
entre les Juifs et les musulmans c'est
un conflit qui est d'abord un conflit
territorial entre israélien et
Palestiniens ça ne peut pas se
transformer en guerre de tous contre
tous et donc nous ne sommes pas nous ne
sommes pas israéliens nous ne sommes pas
Palestiniens nous sommes français et
donc nous avons une parole à adresser
qui est une parole de paix d'équilibre
et qui doit être une parole mesurée qui
ne peut pas chercher elle-même
l'embrasement et donc je je j'essaie je
m'efforce de ne pas tomber dans basculer
dans dans la passion et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'étais à la fois
après le 7 octobre manifesté à l'appel
du CRIF pour manifester notre soutien et
notre solidarité avec le peuple
israélien frappé par le Hamas et que
j'étais samedi dans la rue en solidarité
cette fois-ci avec le peuple palestinien
victime des bombardements de tsal et que
là vous appelez une marche contre
l'antisémitisme est-ce que vous appelez
tous les partis politiques à cette
marche j'ai appelé je sais pas si c'est
une marche j'ai appelé à ce qu'on ait
une initiative commune qui permettent ça
peut être un appel ça peut être une
marche ça peut être un rassemblement et
ça peut être à Paris ça peut être aussi
dans toutes les régions de France
simplement pour un moment marquer notre
refus définitif sans réserve
d'antisémitisme et que toute la classe
politique soit amené à prendre position
et j'ai donc demandé à ce que toutes les
formations politique est ce geste là en
précisant en précisant s'agissant
puisque c'est là où vous voulez
m'emmener en précisant s'agissant du
rassembléement nationale que cela
suppose qu'il rompe avec sa propre
histoire et avec un certain nombre de
ces dirigeants militants cadres qui sont
eux-mêmes marqués par une histoire qui
est liée à l'antisémitisme il n'a pas
fallu 4 heur pour que en fait jandan
bardellaa malheureusement apporte la
démonstration que ce parti n'a rompu en
rien avec son hisoire en rien avec ce
qui a été autrefois l'objet de sa
condamnation unanime qu'a-t-il dit il a
dit Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas
antisémite Jean-Marie Le Pen a été
condamné condamné par la justice à
plusieurs reprises pour négationnisme
pour antisémitisme et avoir aujourd'hui
le patron du rassemblement national qui
vient nous expliquer que non son
prédécesseur n'était pas antisémite ça
montre bien une seule chose c'est que
leur refus l'antisémitisme quand il
s'affichent à la télévision sur les chaî
de radio et cetera il a un seul objectif
c'est d'instrumentaliser cette cause
pour en faire en fait un coup de
bouttoir contre le monde musulman contre
et il ai qu'aujourd'hui son mouvement
est irréprochable ce son son mouvement
ne peut pas être irréprochable alors
même qu'il y a un parlementaire qui est
en fait un ancien libraire négationiste
vous avez y compris dit que les fait de
date de il y a 30 35 ans et
qu'aujourd'hui lui- même est
irréprochable mais il n'est pas
irréprochable quand vous dites que
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas antis
sémite c'est que vous considérez que ces
propos n'étaient pas et pour moi ça
n'est pas un détail c'est effectivement
la preuve que ils n'ont pas changé et
que ça est un artifice et qu'il cherche
simplement à nous endormir à nous
expliquer que en fait l'antisémitisme
est un un mal absolu simplement parce
que en réalité et bien ça sert à à taper
sur le monde musulman voilà c'est la se
chose et mais j'observe aussi qu'ils
n'ont pas rompu avec toute la galaxie de
l'extrême droite grouusculaire avec les
identitaires avec les suprémaacistes
avec tous ces gens-là et qu'ils ont dans
leur rang des gens qui en permanence
sont sont issus de ce parcours et donc
oui il avec rien c estce contenu de
cette déclarations de Jordan Bardella
vous dites ce matin que vous ne
souhaitez pas que le RN soit associé à
votre initiative la preuve est faite
qu'ils ne peuvent pas qu'ils ne
répondent pas aux conditions que j'avais
moi-même fixé qui est de d'avoir une
rupture claire net définitive
avec tout ce tous les liens qu'ils ont
pu entretenir avec la sphère antisémite
et la preuve a été donnée
malheureusement hier qu'ils n'ont rompu
avec rien donc non est-ce que c'était
une erreur dans un premier temps d'avoir
dit que le RN pouvait participer à cette
initiative est-ce que c'est une FA
polique ça j'ai dit en fait à la
condition de donc vous les avez pas
exclu mais je c'est un appel qui doit
être universel chacun devrait prendre
conscience de la gravité de ce qui
antisémitisme personne ne devrait avoir
en France la moindre ambigué par rapport
à l'antisémitisme l'an sémitisme est tu
et donc vous avez
l'obligation
morale civique politique de condamner
l'antisémitisme maintenant évidemment on
ne peut pas être à la fois en soutien de
ceux qui sont antisémite et condanné
antisémitisme c'est la raison pour
laquelle puisque la preuve a été donnée
une nouvelle fois que le RN n'avait pas
rompu avec son histoire avec son
idéologie et bien effectivement ils ne
peuvent pas être aujourd'hui dans un
appel C de cette nature est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez eu des retours
d'autres chefs de parti sur votre appel
non j'ai pas eu encore le temps on était
dimanche j'ai pas voulu déranger qui que
ce soit et donc en fait je n'ai pas
encore appelé les uns et les autres mais
je souhaite que je ne souhaite pas
d'ailleurs avoir le monopole cette
initiative je souhaite qu'elle soit
partagée par le plus grand nombre par le
monde syndical mone associatif par
toutes les organisations antiracistes
par toutes celles et ceux qui ont
vocation à accompagner cette démarche il
s'agit pas d'en faire la démarche
d'Olivier fort ou la démarche du Parti
socialiste c'est une initiative que je
souhaite large et que je souhaite
permettre d'avoir une parole qui soit
une parole la plus forte possible pour
rappeler à nos concitoyens ce qui'est
l'antisémitisme en France est-ce que la
France insoumise doit faire partie de
cet appel selon vous mais c'est à eux
d'en décider c'est pas moi je j'ai lancé
un appel qui un appel qui doit être le
plus univel possible et permettre à
chacun de répondre avec force de
répondre sans ambigué de répondre en
ayant en tête ce qui est antisémitisme
et donc je vous pose la question parce
que François Hollande François Hollande
hier dit qu'il ne pense pas que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon soit antisémite mais que les
positions qu'il prend entretient un
courant antisémite quand il s'est
obstiné à ne pas qualifier le Hamas de
terroriste il a alimenter cette machine
infernale est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça moi je crois que il y a je veux
pas tout mélanger je ne crois pas que la
les insommis soient antisémite je crois
qu'ils ont un sujet effectivement avec
la qualification du Hamas ce qui ne veut
pas dire d'ailleurs qu'il n'est pas
condamné les crimes du Hamas mais pour
eux pour une partie d'entre eux au moins
il y a une forme de confusion avec
l'idée que le Hamas qui est pourtant une
organisation terroriste et de l'islam
radical serait aujourd'hui UNEF une
forme d'armée de résistance pour la
cause palestinienne et pour vous leur
position n'entretient pas à courant
antisémite je ne crois pas qu'ils soit
antisémites et je ne pense pas queils
aient vocation entretenir un courant
antismite simplement je dis qu'ils ont
un sujet effectivement qui est un sujet
de désaccord entre nous et ça a été même
suffisamment souligné de ma part et de
la part de vos confrères il y a sur ce
sujet-l un desésaccord qui est profond
parce que moi je considère que ne pas
qualifier le Hamas rajoute au malheur du
monde pour paraphraser Albert Camu et
donc mais il y a pas ça dire que yal
brun pivé camp pelle à vive c'est pas il
y a pas une forme de d'antisémitisme
dans ces propos écoutez ça franchement
il y a des polémiques parfois qui euh me
paraisse un peu hors de propos en fait
je ne pense pas que quand il dit camp à
TelAviv il est en tête en fait de faire
une allusion euh au camp de la mort
autrement ce serait effectivement
redoutablement euh grave mais je n'ai
pas pensé un seul instant que ça puisse
être le cas et j'aimerais que euh nous
n'ayons pas à l'esprit une polémique par
jour dans ce sujet-là l'objectif n'est
pas de diviser mais de rassembler le
plus grand nombre sur une position qui
doit être une position équilibrée une
position qui à la fois de soutien au
peuple israélien quand il est menacé
dans sa sécurité et en même temps de
refus de représail aveugle qui sont là
aussi un potentiel crime de guerre et
risque génocidaire dit l'ONU du coup
suite à aux positions de la France
insoumise sur le Hamas le PS a voté un
moratoire sur sa participation à l' nuU
jusqu'à quand ce moratoire mais écoutez
on a posé des conditions nous souhaitons
en fait pouvoir discuter de tout ce qui
nous a opposé pendant 18 mois que
s'est-il passé pendant 18 mois nous
aurions dû progresser nous n'avons pas
progressé nous avons au mieux stagné
parfois même régressé alors que les
sujets qui étaient devant nous étaient
des sujets qui étaient des sujets sur
laquel lesquels la gauche aurait dû
pouvoir faire entendre sa voix de
manière unanime et pouvoir embrasser une
opinion large je pense évidemment au
sujet des retraites sur lequel nous
avons eu un premier sujet de désaccord
puis ensuite sur la question des
violences urbaines ou parce que la
phrase retenue a été celle de ne pas
appeler au calme mais d'appeler à la
justice je peux comprendre le sens de ce
qui a été dit mais comment pouvait-on
nous qui avons tant d'élus de Mair de
conseill municipaux d'adjoint qui se
bataiit soir après soir pour empêcher
qu'on brûle une médiathèque qu'on brûle
une mairie qu'on brûle un équipement
publicque qu'on brûle un centre
commercial comme ça a été le cas dans ma
circonscription comment voulez-vous que
en fait on puisse se comprendre dans ces
moments-là bien sûr qu'il y a des causes
à cela il y avait un fait générateur la
mort de Naël et puis il y avait aussi la
Constitution ces ghettos géants qui sont
devenus certains de nos quartiers c'est
vrai mais ça ne suppose pas de laisser
penser un seul instant qu'il puisse y
avoir la moindre compassion pour des des
jeunes mais mais qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de la France insoumise et de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour mettre fin à ce
moratoire est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que le PS pourra renouer avec
l'anupe comme avant mais je souhaite que
nous puissions discuter d'abord il y a
pas que Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans l'anupe
il y a en fait cinq formations
politiques et je souhaite que l'ensemble
de ces formations se pose la question de
savoir comment effectivement on fait
mieux pour
reprendre mais c'est à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui-même de dire dans quel
état d'esprit il est quand on estourd'ui
c'est lui le problème clairiv mais j'ai
déjà dit qu'il y avit un problème avecth
Mélenchon et donc je peux me répéter si
vous le souhaitez mais ce que je dis
c'est que
il évidence c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
était celui qui à un moment deux moments
dans l'histoire de la République
française a été le mieux placé à gauche
pour pouvoir atteindre un second tour
c'était le cas dans cette élection
présidentielle et dans la précédente à
chaque fois il a commis la même erreur
c'estàdire que au lieu de chercher à
devenir le centre de gravité de toute la
gauche et de faire en sorte de pouvoir
être son expression commune il a choisi
contraire de se replier sur son propre
socle électoral et de radicaliser à
chaque fois ses positions au prix
de faire de faire en sorte que une
partie de ses partenaires ne se retrouve
plus dans les mots qui qu'il prononce
dans les revendications qu'il porte et
donc c'est sa responsabilité et
l'évidence aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ne
cherche pas à être le candidat de toute
la gauche quand on cherche à être le
candidat de toute la gauche on fait en
sorte d'essayer de parler en fait même
ne serait-ce que d'appeler ses
partenaires de chercher à avoir des
positions communes et de faire en sorte
d'avancer donc vous cherchez à
reconstruire la gauche sans lui je
cherche à construire une offre politique
qui soit celle d'un rassemblement de la
gauche et des écologistes qui se fasse
en dans le respect de chacun et avec la
possibilité de parvenir ensuite à un
projet commun et à une incarnation
commune pour l'élection présidentielle
le Sénat entame cet après-midi l'examen
de la loi immigration plus d'un an après
sa présentation dans un sondage publié
par Le Parisien 87 % des Français
pensent qu'il faut changer les règles en
matière d'immigration est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas en décalage en votant en ne
votant pas ce texte mais ça m'arrive de
ne pas être majoritaire et d'ailleurs je
ne le suis pas ni aussi au Sénat ni à
l'Assemblée donc est-ce que ça doit
m'empêcher de défendre des positions
auxquelles je crois la politique ça
n'est pas simplement de s'igner sur des
sondages c'est de chercher d'ailleurs à
les faire bouger et d'expliquer pourquoi
on n'est pas d'accord mais moi je ne
peux pas être d'accord avec un
gouvernement qui cherche en réalité à
constituer une majorité sur des
positions qui sont celles de la droite
sénatoriale qui elle-même calque ses
positions sur l'extrême droite comment
voulez-vous que j'accepte d'être
entraîné semaine après semaine sur des
positions qui sont de pire en pire on a
tout à l'heure parlé l'antisémitisme
mais pour moi la lutte contre le racisme
ne se divise pas il n'y a pas d'un côté
l'antisémitisme qu'il faudrait condamner
et en même temps le racisme qu'il
faudrait légitimer et donc je suis
farouchement opposé à ce texte et opposé
au dérivve que j'observe tout à l'heure
vous en parliez avec vous en parliez
avec l'invité précédent monsieur
boncur et j'entendais ce qu'il disait
mais y compris la justification même si
lui est plus plus nuancé c'est un
centriste mais la justification par les
républicains aujourd'hui de la fin de
l'aide médicale d'État se Rendon compte
de ce que l'on est en train de faire et
quand je dis ça ce n'est pas une
position des socialistes c'est une
position du corps médical qui a dit
c'était la fois une faute éthique une
faute financière budgétaire et donc une
faute sanitaire donc vous entendez les
Français les Français ils sont
favorables à un durcissement des règles
en matière d'immigration pour vous il
faut pas les durcir mais ça veut rien
dire en fait les les règles actuelles
sont déjà en réalité de nature quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui pose des
problèmes de sécurité nationale il est
déjà expulsable ça n c'est une c'est un
mensonge que d'expliquer que en fait il
faudrait de nouvelles règles à chaque
fois la réalité c'est que nous n'avons
hier soir Géral nous avons cessé de
légiférer depuis des années et des
années ça fait ça va être le 20e texte
en je ne sais plus combien d'années
enfin bref on n pas arrêté de légiférer
sur ce sujet là ça n'a rien changé
aujourd'hui on a une situation qui est
assez paradoxale vous avez maintenant
Géral Darmanin qui nous explique euh que
il faudrait euh en fait expulser à deux
bras mais il sait bien que ce n'est pas
le cas 7 % des cttf sont exécutés en
réalité et on a cette situation assez
folle c'est que vous avez des gens qui
travaillent qui sont donc là qui sont
insérrés qui payent des cotisations mais
qui n'ont droit à rien parce que ils
restent dans l'illégalité et donc vous
avez cette espèce de zone grise
impossible vous avez des gens qui ne
peuvent pas s'intégrer correctement
parce que tout simplement en fait on ne
peut pas expulser et on ne veut pas
intégrer alors qu'est-ce qu' on veut pas
régulariser alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
et bien la proposition que nous nous
faisons c'est que toutes celles et ceux
qui ont une vie dans notre pays qui ont
un travail qui est un travail qui est un
travail légal et bien cela puisse être
régularisé et faire en sorte que avec
leurs enfants avec leurs femmes avec
leurs mari et bien ils puissent vivre
dans de bonnes conditions et participer
à publblains disent que c'est un appel
d'air l'article 3 qui régularise
uniquement dans les métiers en tension
c'est-à-dire moins que ce que vous vous
proposezv oui mais c'est déjà enfin
c'est vrai que ça n'est même pas ce que
nous proposons nous mais moi je vous
parler de ce que je propose ce que nous
proposons nous donc mais vous pensez
qu'il figurera dans le texte cet article
3 mais je nen sais rien je vois que en
fait a déjà prévu de lâcher du l'Est il
a prévu en fait de tout leur donner je
me souviens d'une interview il avait dit
tout ce que veulent les républicains je
le veux aussi donc on voit bien que son
objectif à lui la quasi intégralité et
son objectif à lui est en réalité de
trouver une majorité élargie au
républicains et n'est pas réalité de
satisfaire l'intérêt général donc de ce
point de vue nous ne serons jamais
d'accord voilà Emmanuel Macron vous a
écrit une lettre vous et aux autres
chefs de parti hier soir il confirme
qu'il est favorable à un élargissement
du référendum notamment aux questions
migratoires est-ce que c'est une bonne
chose ben vous avez compris dans la
droite ligne de ce que je viens de vous
dire qu'il y a un appel non pas d'air un
appel du pied au Républicain qui le
réclame à cor et comme le RN et donc il
est là pour leur dire je vais vous
satisfaire et je vais vous donner ce
nouveau gage de ma confiance et donc en
retour j'espère votre confiance mais ce
deal là je n'y participerai jamais
surtout si vous avez lu le texte qu'il
nous a envoyé c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire il nous dit je suis prêt
à un référendum sur l'immigration mais
alors par contre sur les super profit
réforme fiscale ça c'est pas possible et
puis puisque en fait il faut aller
jusqu'au bout vous voulez vous un
référendum sur la retraite et bien je
vous dis c'est impossible aussi on ne
pourra pas toucher en fait à la réforme
des retraites à avant 5 ans voilà ce que
nous dit Emmanuel Macron donc la ficelle
est grosse c'estd les référendum pour la
droite et l'extrême droite j'y suis
favorable les référendums que propose la
gauche sur les super profits ou sur la
réforme des retraites alors là c'est
impossible écoutez la ficelle est trop
grosse pour que je participe à cette
mascarade mais est-ce que ça veut dire
que vous n'irez pas à la prochaine
rencontre de saintnil 17 je je ne pense
pas enfin effectivement quand je vois en
fait ce que nous écrit le chef de l'État
laissant penser que aujourd'u
aujourd'hui il y aurait une forme de
nouveau scénacle qu'il aurait qu'il
aurait inventé alors le Parlement on n
parle plus toute façon il marche au 493
mais vous avez pendant ce temps-là en
fait une espèce de cénacle qui serait
avec quelques happy fu avec quelques
privilégiés qui auraient la chance de
parler avec le chef de l'État les chefs
de parti qui feraient leur tambouille
entre eux mais c'est
non c'est non parce que je ne veux pas
supprimer le Parlement je crois à la
démocratie je crois au fait que en fait
il y a des lieux où on puisse voter dans
ces rendez-vous que le chef de l'État
nous n'avons jamais y compris voter nous
sommes simplement là pour donner un avis
et après il essaie de faire croire que
ayant donné notre avis il a réussi à
trouver une synthèse qu'il produirait
devant les Français et que qui serait le
résultat d'un consensus global entre
nous mais il n'y a jamais eu de
consensus sur aucun sujet d'ailleurs et
c'est bien naturel parce que la
démocratie c'est pouvoir faire des choix
et moi je ne veux pas laisser penser que
désormais il n'y a plus de choix il y
aurait plus qu'un seul choix possible
c'est président de la République donc ça
c'est pas possible donc vous n'irez pas
pourtant vous êtes allé à la précédente
rencontre mais je suis un républicain et
donc quand je suis invité par le chef de
l'État à une première démarche qui nous
dit écoutez je voudrais discuter avec
vous je vais pas refuser de discuter
maintenant quand je vois quel est
l'ordre du jour qui nous est proposé
venir valider en fait le deal qu'il veut
passer avec la droite et l'extrême
droite pardon mais enfin je ne suis pas
là pour tenir la chandelle donc je ne
ferai pas en fait euh office de je ne
sais quoi donc voilà il y a pas de
possibilité pour moi s'il veut se marier
avec la droite et pousser le
raisonnement jusqu'à l'extrême droite
grand bien lui fe ce sera sans Mo merci
Olivier fort merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin on passe au club
des territoires